rebellion has announced that sniper  elite 4 has been delayed from its  original 2016 release window and will  now arrive on a brief 14 of next year  the latest entry in the sniper elite  series has you step into the shoes of  agent Kyle fairburn as you help the  Italian resistance save innocent  citizens and fight fascism in their  country earlier this year a teaser  trailer for the game was released which  shows off the Italian countryside tanks  and presumably the soldiers you'll be  pointing your sniper rifle at rebellion  have announced that the game will arrive  on ps4 xbox one and pc for all the  latest news demos as other bits and  pieces stay tuned against pipe  you